so is labor planning on throwing its
weight behind this idea by the Lib Dems
and the SNP to have an election on the
9th of December oh I mean that this live
down plan is a sort of opportunistic
stunts have a freight I mean it's
entirely sort of ridiculous it would
need cross-party support to go through
to get through the House of Commons
procedures and then it then it would be
subject to all kinds of amendments
particularly when it gets into the house
of laws it's just a stunt so the Lib
Dems can get on the telly today know
that we're in this situation discussing
whether or not we should have an
election because Boris Johnson has
utterly failed on his signature policy
to deliver brexit do-or-die on October
31st and the Labour Party's position
remains its principled position we want
a general election but we're not going
to go through a general election until
we have gotten absolute reassurance that
a No Deal brexit has ruled out and we've
got an understanding from the European
Commission about the extension date and
we're still waiting for that
clarification from the EU interesting
that you say that it's a stunt with the
Lib Dems Nikki Morgan says it's a stunt
by the Lib Dem something I didn't expect
to do on this morning's program is is
unite to those their guests on this
matter now on the subject of an election
Jeremy Corbyn is called for an election
35 times he told me two weeks ago we're
ready for an election any time we want
to go out and campaign last month John
MacDonald told the show general election
bring it on so can you just explain why
if an extension is granted by the EU to
the end of January why does it labor
want to see an election well they're
still waiting for that clarification and
we don't have it yet so when we get like
time we can go through until it happens
well I mean the Lib Dems like isn't good
the Lib Dem plan would depend on the
government and others allowing it to go
in the order paper it's not going to
happen it's just a sideshow it's a
distraction we're waiting for the
clarification from the EU about the
extension day because we don't trust
Boris Johnson we don't trust him to
cruncher not crush us out with a
damaging No Deal brexit so that is why
we're adopting a principled responsible
position waiting to see
happens in the next 24-48 hours but yes
we do want the general lecture I mean
when you've got four and a half million
people waiting for treatment in the NHS
then we want an election when you've got
over 600,000 people in the last year
languishing on trolleys in corridors in
hospitals we want a general election one
we've got our young people denied the
mental health support that they need of
course we want a general election but we
but we've got to make sure that we get
those absolute reassurances that Boris
Johnson won't use a general election and
the campaign too crashes out of the
European Union with a disastrous No Deal
brexit well this is the point isn't it I
mean you've just said it you know with
every day that you delay liking an
election is another day where in your
words you know the NHS is in crisis so
let me just try and phrase the question
slightly differently if the EU does
grant an extension until the end of
January which is not a wild hypothetical
it's what's expected we'll labour then
back in early elections well I mean you
vote you put the finger on the dilemma
that faces me is the shadow health
secretary every day that Matt Hancock is
the health secretary another 300 people
waked beyond 18 weeks for treatment in
the health service that's people waiting
longer in pain in agony in distress
under Matt Hancock and Boris Johnson
because they've been running down the
NHS for a decade so look I too want that
general election because I want to start
rebuilding the NHS but we have to wait
and see what the European Union clarify
about an extension date and if they give
us that extension until January then
we'll have to consider it but at the
moment we don't have that clarification
and we cannot support Boris Johnson's
plans until we've got an absolute
reassurance that no deal is off the
table you see I don't really want to
sound like a broken record here but it's
one thing to say oh yeah we'll consider
it when the EU come back but we're
expecting them to come back in a matter
of days we're expecting them to come
back potentially with this extension to
the end of January so why can't you just
be straight with people about whether or
not you'd back an election at that time
if the EU extends to the extend of
January will labor back
but but but with there's lots of
speculation that the e you're going to
come back with various different dates
and that's the issue so until we know
the exact dates they come back with then
we'll be able to make our judgment what
we do but I want to reassure you we are
desperate for a general election when
you've got thirty-two thousand people
waiting beyond two months for cancer
treatment and now that every cancer
target is worsened in the last year
under under Matt Hancock and now Boris
Johnson we need that general election
but we are not going to countenance an
election well No Deal is still a
possibility we've got to get an absolute
reassurance that No Deal is completely
off the table and that is what we're
waiting for it's a truth that you
stalling about the general election
simply because you don't trust people to
vote the way that you want you don't
think that you would win it no yeah I'm
confident that once we start making the
arguments about the future of the
National Health Service the future of
living standards about climate change
about the future of our schools which
are being cuts under these stories then
we'll begin to win the confidence of the
British people because this country
needs a change of direction and I know
you're about they'll say to me look at
the opinion polls are terrible and
they're not create for the Labour Party
I'm not daft I can see that but they
weren't that great in the last general
lecture and we made up a lot of ground
so I think when we go out there and we
talk about our vision for the country
about rebuilding our NHS and giving
every child the best education in our
schools I think we'll be able to win
people over to our program you see I
know that you want to talk about all
these domestic issues and I'm very happy
to talk about all of Labour's domestic
issues in an election campaign when you
know they'll be on your manifesto but it
just can you see why some people are
frustrated that you just don't seem to
be able to get a answer from Labour
about whether or not they support a
December election or not is it because
there's a split in the party what's
going on I mean there's always there's
awfully different opinions in the Labour
Party about the tactics of an election
um you can read that in today's
newspapers I can't pretend there's not
different opinions but the priority for
us is to get a general election when No
Deal is off the table and we want that
general election so we can focus on the
NHS and school
making our streets safer after the years
of cuts to police officers under these
Tories but we're not going to walk into
a trap
of Boris Johnson loose who's trying to
distract everybody because remember he
hasn't delivered on his pledge his
solemn pledge to the British people that
he deliver brexit do or die
by October 31st and now he soft we've
drawn the withdrawal bell and he's even
talking about going on strike I mean
when you've got six hundred thousand
people languishing on trolleys in
corridors in hospitals not even able to
get a bed and this government are
talking about going on strike when so
many people are denied treatment I mean
it's a joke it's disgusting actually I'm
keen to talk about the really serious
news that's come out this week as well
about the thirty-nine people and found
dead in the back of a refrigerated
trailer attached to a lorry this week we
don't know the circumstances of their
deaths we don't know what drew them to
make that awful decision to get into the
back of that container but we do know
that this is the kind of thing that is
happening in the United Kingdom are you
worried that MPs are just taking their
eye off the ball when it comes to stuff
like this really really serious issues
because we're having all these rouser
that break soon
I mean what's happened in that with that
container it's just unspeakably horrific
isn't it and I mean that the the story
that was on the front page of the
newspapers yesterday about the young
woman texting their mother saying I
can't breathe I mean I mean it's
heartbreaking wasn't it and the fact
that people must be so desperate to
climb into a container to travel across
the world to get to this country
it's heart-rending and and this human
trafficking that is going on it is
immoral and we need to ensure that the
authorities the police and others have
got there I've got the resources and
you're right these issues should be
getting debated properly in the House of
Commons I mean this week in the House of
Commons I brought a motion to end
privatization in our NHS I mean Lib Dems
by the way abstained on air
I can understand why they abstained in
it but they did but these issues aren't
getting the kind of the focus that they
should get when you've got so many
people on the waiting list four and a
half million and the waiting list no NHS
it's not getting
the focus in the House of Commons that
they should get at the moment so yes I I
do share your frustration that there are
so many big important issues which
really need the focus of government and
they're not getting them which is why
again I convert through its Oakley
offensive that the government are
talking about going on strike when
there's so many big issues facing the
country